[Music]
doctor I want to talk about salt a lot
of people have high blood pressure to
stay away from salt but we need it
well the salt is an essential nutrient
sodium and chloride you cannot have
nerve impulses without sodium chloride
they're an integral part of the
biochemical system of a nerve
transmission you cannot move water
around in your body or retain in the
right compartments inside your blood
vessels inside your tissues inside the
cells
you can't keep things in the right
compartment without sodium chloride the
chief cells in your stomach cannot make
stomach acid without salt okay salted
zz'rot material sodium chloride is the
raw material to make hydrochloric acid
you're sorry now two things have
happened because of this terrible
criminal advice that doctors have given
it's criminal
anybody else do this to the American
people they be put in jail for life some
of them be executed because of the
number of people who are killed over
this right mm-hmm
salt is required to make stomach acid
you don't have enough stomach acid you
get reflux incorrectly called acid
reflux
it's reflux reflux is caused by
insufficient amounts of stomach acid not
too much stomach acid so doctors have
named it the wrong thing right and
basically you get reflux when you don't
have enough stomach acid to keep your
stomach environments t'rul so yeast
begin to grow in there so you eat
carbohydrates and sugar they ferment
that produced gas all heartburn pressure
reflux because you have all these things
growing in your stomach okay when you
get a pH too high you get a pH about
four all these things begin to grow you
have a pH under one your pepsin works to
digest proteins and you can absorb
minerals you can absorb b12 your pH gets
above to two and a half you can't do
that okay so you're in trouble I mean
you can take tons of iron
supplementation and if you don't have
any stomach acids you can't absorb iron
now here comes the most terrible thing
that's happened to America because of
this inappropriate advice well there's
two things one you go back to 1995 and
750 people died during a triple digit
heat wave in Chicago it was a two-week
heatwave 1995
it was 750 people died here in Chicago
and thousands of people fell out with
heatstroke
the first thing they give them
intravenously on the way to the hospital
he had he stroked a saline solution
which is saltwater yeah and it's
absolutely criminal that the 750 people
who died we're all ones were on a salt
restricted that they're all seniors who
are on a salt restricted diet they died
of heatstroke because of these doctors
didn't have the courtesy to call these
people up and good manners just to call
up and say look whether you believe in
the salt restricted out or not right now
you need to put a couple of tablespoons
of salt in the gallon water he's sipping
on that until the heatwave goes away but
they didn't do that and so all those
people who died of heatstroke we're
under the care of doctors who are on a
restricted salt diet those doctors
should be put in jail okay
for almost like the same thing as
vehicular homicide the same type of
thing as manslaughter right type of
thing then here comes the big one right
now on the average from this is a Mayo
Clinic study came out in 2009 they said
that as many as 30% 30 people out of a
hundred America now have celiac disease
and have trouble absorbing nutrients and
as a result there's people with 25
legitimately diagnosed diseases which
are all nutritional deficiency diseases
they're going to 18 different
specialists for all this
they're paying you know tens of
thousands of dollars a day to deal with
this and it's simply a gluten
intolerance and they can't their
intestines or damaged they can't absorb
nutrients well when you can't digest
wheat barley around oat glutens and you
absorb these big chunks of what's called
polypeptides your body recognizes and
sets up an intolerance to those
partially digested proteins you get
gluten intolerance you get celiac
disease or bowel syndrome inflammatory
bowel disease diverticulitis ulcerative
colitis Crohn's disease
the doctors approach to these diseases
or cut your intestines out I can't
understand how they you know you have a
malabsorption problem they want to cut
your intestines out there's really dumb
any rate because they have you on a
salt restricted diet you cannot make
stomach acid so your pepsin won't work
and you cannot digest proteins including
the protein of wheat brought around oats
now again there's a big research project
come out in 2009 that said oh oh it used
to be people got celiac disease when
they were kids
and if you recognize you can save them
from all these terrible diseases because
you can get them off of gluten and
they'd be fine well now people who could
eat gluten with impunity they were
really big on eating wheat barley rye
oats no problems it's only now at age 50
or 60 they become gluten intolerant
well that's because over the years on a
salt restricted diet they couldn't
digest wheat barley rounded glutens down
to their simplest amino acids big chunks
called polypeptides are being absorbed
they set up an intolerance to it and now
at age 50 60 we have 80 out of a hundred
people with gluten intolerance because
of this criminal advice to restrict salt
[Music]
you